[Aplausos]
[Música]
lo sabemos la inmigración es un tema
candente en los eeuu y desde luego es un
tema polarizante puedes estar a favor o
estar en contra pero difícilmente vas a
permanecer impasible o consideras que la
inmigración es una oportunidad o una
amenaza
[Música]
sin embargo queridos amigos de visual
política en los eeuu existe otro tipo de
inmigración de la que no se habla tanto
pero que supone que cada año un enorme
flujo de personas se traslade de un
territorio a otro te estoy hablando de
la inmigración interestatal entre los
propios estados que conforman los eeuu
algo que hace que haya estados ganadores
y estados perdedores fue a blues cuidar
muchos además amigos ahora con la última
reforma fiscal liderada por donald trump
y el partido republicano todo apunta a
que este tipo de inmigración va a crecer
evidentemente tal y como os podéis
imaginar las personas suelen emigrar a
los territorios más prósperos así que
hay unas cuantas preguntas que todos
podemos hacernos que está ocurriendo en
los eeuu que supone este tipo de
inmigración que estados son los
ganadores y cuáles los perdedores porque
lo son o qué podemos esperar en el
futuro
pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
ganadores y perdedores
cada año miles y miles millones de
estadounidenses hacen las maletas y se
trasladan a vivir a otro estado
[Música]
y evidentemente tal y como podéis
suponer hay estados que cada año tienen
saldos positivos de inmigración es decir
que año tras año son más los
compatriotas que llegan que los que se
marchan y también claro lo contrario
algunos estados ven como cada año muchos
vecinos se mudan a otro estado muchos
más de los que llegan porque lo que
ocurre no es ni más ni menos que los
estados compiten entre sí
claro cada estado tiene sus propias
características sus propias regulaciones
sus propios impuestos su política y
lógicamente esto hace que algunos
estados sean más prósperos que otros
evidentemente la gente suele mudarse a
lugares más prósperos a estados donde
hay más trabajo mejores condiciones de
vida en los que se están instalando más
empresas bien el caso es que cada año
según los datos del irc del servicio de
impuestos internos la agencia del
gobierno federal que se encarga de
recaudar los impuestos en 2016 el último
año con datos cerrados se mudaron de
estado el 28 por ciento de todos los
contribuyentes según este dato y os
aseguro que en los eeuu el servicio de
impuestos tiene probablemente los
mejores datos del país la tasa de
emigración de movilidad interna de los
eeuu es muy pero que muy alta comparada
con otros países desarrollados
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dicho esto queréis saber cuáles son los
estados con mayor migratorio de
estadounidenses es decir los estados
donde cada año es mayor la diferencia
entre los estadounidenses que se marchan
y los que llegan pues fijaos
[Música]
si ya lo veis nueva york está a la
cabeza entre los estados menos
atractivos para la llegada de
estadounidenses
tan solo en 2016 se marcharon en
términos netos una vez descontadas las
llegadas más de 150.000 norteamericanos
les sigue en otros estados como illinois
new jersey o california california
alguien podría imaginarse que california
la tierra de la tecnología las playas
kilométricas y el buen tiempo estuviera
la lista pues sí ya lo veis por cierto
para todos los que nos veis desde
california
un saludo enorme y todo nuestro apoyo
por los difíciles momentos que estéis
atravesando como consecuencia de los
incendios forestales desde aquí desde
visual político un fuerte abrazo y ahora
la pregunta contraria
cuáles son los estados con mayor
superávit migratorio de estadounidenses
atentos
[Música]
florida con un saldo positivo de unos
200.000 estadounidenses florida se ha
convertido en la gran ganadora
estos son los datos de 2016 pero si en
vez de tomar el último año con datos
disponibles tomamos un periodo de tiempo
más amplio por ejemplo desde comienzos
de los 90 el resultado es prácticamente
el mismo
nuevayork california e illinois fueron
los estados que más estadounidenses
perdieron mientras que florida arizona y
texas fueron los que más norteamericanos
ganaron
y ojo porque esto es mucho más
importante de lo que parece a simple
vista recordáis el vídeo que hicimos
hace poco sobre la deuda oculta de los
estados pues amigos cada vez que un
estado pierde estadounidenses está
perdiendo muchísima riqueza por ejemplo
los casi 200.000 norteamericanos que en
términos netos se fueron a vivir a
florida en 2016 tuvieron ese año unos
ingresos de más de 17 mil millones de
dólares unos ingresos que a partir de
ahora se producirán en florida una parte
de ellos se ahorrará en las entidades
financieras de este estado otra parte se
gastará en tiendas supermercados cines
restaurantes y gasolineras de florida
claro y otra parte se invertirá en
nuevas empresas y nuevos negocios que
estarán fundamentalmente en florida
todo esto amigos supone más riqueza más
trabajo y también más ingresos fiscales
para este estado veis lo importante que
es ya no parece tan poca cosa verdad
ahora bien visto todo esto la pregunta
que podemos hacernos es qué variables
explican todo este movimiento de
personas atentos
la competencia
[Aplausos]
son muchos los motivos que hacen que las
personas se muden de un lugar a otro
familia trabajo clima oportunidades
universidades sin embargo si tomamos
todos los datos de forma agregada hay un
par de factores que destacan sobre otros
y uno de ellos son los impuestos
en 2016 casi 600.000 personas se mudaron
de los 25 estados con impuestos más
altos a los 25 estados con impuestos más
bajos de hecho de los 25 estados con
impuestos más altos ni más ni menos que
24 tuvieron emigración neta es decir
vieron marchar a más norteamericanos de
los que vieron llegar
y es que amigos a pesar de lo que a
veces se dice la inmigración interior no
está motivada por el clima ni por cosas
parecidas mientras que california sufre
este déficit un estado común johan ser
pequeño frío montañoso y con apenas una
estrecha línea de costa ha registrado
superávit desde el año 2000 y ojo porque
los vecinos del estado de joshua barlett
rhode island vermont massachusetts todos
ellos con impuestos mucho más altos
pierden norteamericanos cada año y es
que si johan ser es ni más ni menos que
el segundo estado con los impuestos más
bajos de los eeuu coincidencia ni de
lejos
lo mismo ocurre en el medio oeste
mientras que dakota del sur en general
registra año tras año superávit
migratorio de norteamericanos sus
estados vecinos con impuestos más altos
nebraska iowa y minnesota han tenido
déficits migratorios cinco años seguidos
y también tenemos a a kentucky frente a
tennessee oa california frente a nevada
texas o washington los estados con
impuestos más altos pierden y los
estados con impuestos más bajos ganan
aún más un estudio elaborado por
economistas del departamento del tesoro
estimó que cuando new yersey subió en
2004 el impuesto estatal sobre la renta
en casi 25 puntos provocó el cambio de
residencia la huida de más de 80
millonarios cada año puede no parecer
mucho pero lo cierto es que las rentas
altas son las que proporcionalmente más
impuestos pagan pero un momento junto a
los impuestos están también las
regulaciones por ejemplo y tal vez
especialmente las que afectan a la
vivienda veréis una combinación de altos
impuestos a la propiedad y muchas
regulaciones y limitaciones para
construir hacen que vivir en un estado
pueda ser muchísimo pero que muchísimo
más caro que vivir en otro es lo que
ocurre precisamente en california los
californianos hartos con los costes de
vivienda y los impuestos huyen del
estado en gran número amigos el alquiler
de un apartamento en las vegas' o en
phoenix cuesta de media menos de la
mitad de lo que cuesta un apartamento
similar que los ángeles o san francisco
cuando vimos hace poco tiempo aquí en
visual político cómo surgió silicon
valley reparamos en que en toda esta
zona no había grandes edificios os
acordáis ahora podéis entender por qué
toda esta zona estanca
poca vivienda y mucha demanda precio por
las nubes
[Música]
y claro esto hace que a muchas personas
les compense mudarse de estado incluso
aunque vayan a ganar menos pero bien
esto ha sido así hasta ahora y lo cierto
es que podemos decir que el efecto hasta
el momento ha sido muy pero que muy
importante los estados que tienen
superávit migratorio son estados que
también han sido capaces de crecer más
en parte por tener políticas más
atractivas para las empresas los
emprendedores y como hemos visto también
los trabajadores pero amigos de aquí en
adelante todo apunta a que el efecto va
a ser aún mayor todo gracias a donald
trump y la reforma fiscal del partido
republicano atentos
[Música]
más competencia
tal vez una de las mejores cosas que ha
hecho donald trump la reforma fiscal de
finales de 2017 no sólo supuso mejorar
la fiscalidad a las empresas sino
también impulsar la competencia entre
los estados me explicó hasta ahora el
gobierno federal subvencionado una parte
de los impuestos estatales esto es
porque eran deducibles lo que pagaba el
estado te lo descontaba de los impuestos
que tenías que pagar al gobierno federal
era algo así como un incentivo a que los
estados subieron los impuestos
pues bien la reforma fiscal ha limitado
esta situación de tal forma que el
número de hogares que podrán deducirse
los impuestos locales estatales ha
pasado de 42 millones en 2017 a unos 17
millones en 2018 y además con importes
de la deducción mucho más pequeñas y
esto amigos ha sido el equivalente a una
subida automática de impuestos en los
estados con impuestos más altos porque
ahora sus contribuyentes tendrán que
pagar íntegro el impuesto estatal y
prácticamente íntegro el impuesto
federales
por ejemplo según cálculos de la
fundación el cato un contribuyente del
estado de nueva york al que en 2017 le
hubiera correspondido a un tipo del 33%
en el impuesto de la renta federal y 30
mil dólares en impuestos estatales y
locales podría haberse reducido los
impuestos federales en 10 mil dólares es
decir gracias a la deducción los
impuestos estatales y locales le
hubieran costado 20 mil dólares en
cambio ahora con la reforma tributaria
tendrá que pagar 30 mil dólares por los
impuestos estatales y locales un 33 por
ciento más y eso se nota
vaya que si se nota por tanto amigos
ahora las diferencias entre los estados
con impuestos más altos y los estados
con impuestos más bajos serán mucho
mayores quizás si los estados con
impuestos altos no tuvieran esta muleta
federal para apoyar su enorme gasto
tendrían que bajar impuestos para ser
competitivos
ronald reagan de hecho según ha
publicado recientemente el wall street
journal se está produciendo en florida
un auge los compradores adinerados que
quieren comprar inmuebles en este estado
para establecer allí su residencia
sabéis por qué en florida no hay
impuesto estatal sobre la renta y sus
impuestos sobre la propiedad son también
relativamente bajos
[Música]
en fin sabéis lo que significa todo esto
amigos bienvenidos a una nueva era de
competencia entre los estados de los
eeuu los gobiernos estatales a partir de
ahora van a tener mucha más presión para
gestionar bien sus presupuestos la buena
noticia es que la evidencia nos dice que
eso termina siendo algo bueno para todos
en fin amigos
esta es la rivalidad creciente que entre
bastidores empiezan a tener los estados
de los eeuu cit ha resultado interesante
este vídeo ayúdanos dándole a like y
compartiéndolo con tus amigos y por
supuesto si aún no lo has hecho no dudes
en suscribirte a visual político un
saludo y hasta la próxima
gente
[Música]
[Aplausos]